Sophia Aram Guillaume Meury c'est tout
ça là tous les les bobos la France Inter
qui sont toute la journée en train de de
boire des des cafés au Café de Flore là
où je sais où hein
j'irai bien savoir ce qu'il faut pour
les gens pour moi avec les impôts parce
que c'est nous qui les payons je vous le
dis ça demande d'un outil de France
Inter je vous le dis qui nous mettent de
la journée qui font rien pour les autres
qui pensent qu'à leur petite gueule à
aller prendre aller boire des verres en
Stan Smith je peux vous dire j'espère
les croiser un jour comme vous le savez
je recouvre régulièrement à la pratique
des lavements au café dont je parle
amplement à mes étudiants de l'académie
de la vie en mouvement voilà c'est un
peu le George Clooney mais du lion froid
il se met
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'on perd un peu en saveur sur
les arabica sanction maximale entre
Grégoire de Fournas après un vote à
l'assemblée le député RN est frappé
d'une exclusion temporaire interdit des
missiles pour les 15 prochaines séances
publiques suite à ses propos d'hier
racistes et largement condamné par la
classe politique Louis Boyard sur le
plateau de BFM quelques minutes après
l'incident
qu'avez-vous entendu vous ce que j'ai
entendu ce que tout ce que tout le monde
a dit parce que eux ils étaient en train
d'expliquer que ce serait que la France
insoumise c'est pas vrai la République
en marche elle a été tout aussi indignée
les députés à l'air ils sont indignés et
aujourd'hui
mais moi à ce moment là j'y étais pas
dans l'hémicycle mais tout le monde
l'important c'est de participer il y a
une auto-censure le mot black par
exemple on a écrit un sketch là il y a
pas longtemps pour TF1 on s'est dit ce
que le mot black on peut le dire je dis
bah moi je peux le dire mais peut-être
pas Didier oui c'est tout bête oui on
peut plus dire aux nain maintenant on
dit verticalement concentré moi je dis
plus le téléphone arabe je dis les
Kabyles téléphoniques les Kabyles
téléphoniques oui j'ai invente des mots
kabyle téléphone donc c'est pas mal faut
dire la même chose mais différemment
vous avez compris le concept 15,8
l'écart de salaire entre hommes et
femmes persistent depuis ce matin 9h10
les femmes travaillent en théorie
gratuitement jusqu'à la fin de l'année
à partir du 4 novembre à 9h10 ce matin
les femmes n'étaient plus payées c'est
le calcul des glorieuses les glorieuses
c'est une façon
[Rires]
que le calcul soit juste ah c'est pas du
tout les bonnes places c'est pas du tout
les bonnes classes
que vous mettez là ça fait des années
que je cherche ma place
[Applaudissements]
c'est par un simple message du petit
oiseau bleu que des milliers de salariés
de Twitter ont appris aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient licenciés près de la moitié des
7500 employés pourraient être concernés
si votre emploi n'est pas impacté vous
recevrez un email si votre emploi est
touché vous recevrez une notification
avec tes prochaines étapes sur le réseau
social des centaines de petits coeurs
bleus sont postés par les employés qui
viennent de perdre leur travail je pense
moi que aujourd'hui il faudrait fermer
les réseaux sociaux mais totalement je
pense que oui
on en a marre de voir des stars
justement comme tu dis même pendant le
covid en train de jouer de la guitare
dans la cuisine une star ça doit être
une star ça se voit sur scène ça se voit
comme une star on en a rien à faire chez
elle
l'accès aux locaux de Twitter à lui
était interdit à tous les salariés
aujourd'hui
les gars je crois que je n'ai plus de
boulot on a désactivé à distance mon
ordinateur de travail et j'ai été retiré
de la messagerie un changement brutal
qui Elon Musk avait annoncé dès son
rachat du réseau social il y a une
semaine pour 44 milliards de dollars
nous insistons sur la discipline et
l'esprit d'équipe nous devons collaborer
de façon fructueuse nous croyons que
l'individu ne compte pas seul compte
l'entreprise vous êtes tout mis rouge
quand même pour rappeler la radio
nous sommes sur France 2 et alors la
France 2 c'est rouge ah bon enfin c'est
rouge c'est pas communiste tu veux dire
c'est
France 2 c'est rouge la couleur
les chaînes du groupe TF1 seront de
nouveau accessibles pour les
téléspectateurs des offres Canal+ et TNT
SAT dès lundi
à la bonne heure mais les Français
s'informent et ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle
98% des Français s'informent tous les
jours et la deuxième bonne nouvelle
regardez 77 % grâce à la télévision on
dit la télévision c'est fini et bien non
la preuve les Français s'informent et en
majorité grâce à nous excusez-moi
c'est quoi ces applaudissements de la
Grande Librairie là allons-y vraiment
[Applaudissements]
merci ça c'est des applaudissements la
lecture est une gourmandise vous savez
la phrase de Montaigne il n'est pas une
heure de chagrin qu'une heure de lecture
des chassé et c'est encore perdu mon
Philippe et c'est Montesquieu c'est pas
moi
un jour un jour on y arrivera vous fumez
plus et plus vous faites des retraites
dans les monastères c'est quoi la
prochaine étape c'est l'abstinence
sexuelle c'est fini vous baisez plus
il y a déjà fait
il a déjà fait
j'avais fait un pari avec le producteur
c'est gagné par quel mot Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing a-t-il conclu son dernier
discours de président de la République
au revoir